Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Buonasera, grazie mille per essere qui.
Devo dire che sono un po' spaventata,
perché dopo il delfino empatico,
farsi 18 minuti di filosofia non è facile.
Resistete alla tentazione di scappare,
vi prometto che sarà interessante.
Prima di venire qui,
stavo discutendo il talk con una mia amica
e le ho detto il titolo.
Il titolo è "Intelligenza artificiale
e design intelligente", e lei mi ha detto,
scusa, ma l'empatia che c'entra?
Due giorni dopo stavamo ancora discutendo
sulla rilevanza o meno dell'empatia.
Vi prometto che in 18 minuti
ce la dovremmo fare oggi:
ma se lo faccio bene,
l'empatia sarà una delle ultime parole
che pronuncio questo in questo talk,
perché sarà parte
della risposta a questa domanda:
che cosa significa essere umani,
se le macchine sono intelligenti?
Una domanda un po' superficiale, semplice.
In realtà, quello che è interessante
in questa domanda,
che è un po' nella descrizione
di questo evento di oggi,
è che in realtà è un po' tendenziosa,
perché sembra assumere
che le macchine siano intelligenti
e che, se lo sono, sono intelligenti
come gli esseri umani.
In realtà il "se" in questa domanda
ha una funzione fondamentale:
dobbiamo domandarci se davvero
le macchine siano intelligenti,
e se lo sono che intelligenza hanno.
Quindi io inizierò questo talk
parlandovi un po' di che cos'è
l'intelligenza artificiale, la definiamo;
capire quali sono
i rischi e le opportunità
che questa tecnologia ci presenta,
che dobbiamo evitare o cogliere.
Poi capire come questi rischi,
e queste opportunità,
abbiano un impatto
sugli esseri umani al giorno d'oggi.
Quando si parla di
intelligenza artificiale
le posizioni sono diversissime,
abbiamo un range ampissimo.
Da una parte troviamo
quelli che dicono: "Ah no,
l'intelligenza artificiale è fantastica,
ci farà superare i limiti biologici,
potremo vivere per sempre,
potremo diventare immortali,
faremo una cosa
che si chiama mind uploading:
prendere tutte le informazioni
che sono nel nostro cervello
e trasferirle in una macchina,
che sarà così potente
da diventare un avatar,
noi senza il corpo.
Saremo veramente potentissimi,
intelligentissimi, eterni."
Dall'altra parte dello spettro
ci sono quelli che dicono:
"ah no, l'intelligenza artificiale,
le macchine saranno sempre più potenti,
sempre più raffinate
e saranno in grado di definire
le regole della loro progettazione
e diventeranno
così potenti, così raffinate
da rendere la specie umana
una specie superflua,
ci stermineranno, ci imprigioneranno,
ci faranno schiavi.
Ecco, la Singolarità o la "Singularity",
il "transhumanism", science fiction,
niente a che fare con la ricerca,
niente a che fare con la scienza.
Se vi capita di sentire qualcuno
che vi dice una di queste due cose,
è un bel libro, una bella discussione
per il pub il venerdì sera,
niente a che fare
con la realtà che abbiamo davanti.
L'intelligenza artificiale -
questa è una definizione
un po' accademica,
però è l'unica cosa veramente accademica
di questo talk, quindi abbiate pazienza -
è "una risorsa di agenti autonomi
capaci di interagire e di imparare,
e che possono essere usati
per eseguire compiti
che altrimenti richiederebbero
l'intelligenza umana
per essere eseguiti con successo".
L'abbiamo definita così in un paper
pubblicato l'anno scorso
in "Science Robotics".
Ci sono due cose che sono importanti,
in questa definizione:
la prima ci dice che tipo
di intelligenza hanno le macchine.
Le macchine non sono intelligenti,
non hanno idee, non hanno intuizioni,
non hanno empatia,
non hanno consapevolezza,
non hanno coscienza, non hanno intuizioni
come quelle che possiamo avere noi
quando stiamo facendo
la cosa più semplice.
Le macchine si comportano
come se fossero intelligenti.
Regolare la temperatura di questo teatro
a seconda della temperatura esterna,
di come reagiscono le persone
dentro il teatro;
se lo facessi io, pensereste:
"È intelligente:
ha capito che avevamo freddo,
ha alzato il termostato".
La macchina raggiunge lo stesso obiettivo,
ma non è intelligente.
Ha un comportamento
che noi definiremmo intelligente
se un essere umano lo stesse eseguendo.
L'altro aspetto che è importante
è che l'intelligenza artificiale
ci permette di avere agenti
che sono autonomi e capaci
di interagire e di imparare
mentre interagiscono con l'ambiente.
Noi nella storia dell'umanità
abbiamo avuto macchine automatiche:
l'orologio che portiamo al polso
o certi tipi di macchine.
Ma mai macchine autonome.
Ed è questa autonomia,
che non è quella degli esseri umani,
che crea i problemi, i rischi,
ma anche le opportunità che l'intelligenza
artificiale ci presenta.
Vi parlo un po' dei rischi,
ma voglio in realtà parlare di più
di cose positive, quindi di opportunità.
Il primo rischio ha a che fare
con il "profiling":
avrete sentito, ne hanno parlato
gli speakers prima di me,
è quello che permette a Google
di farci avere informazioni
che sono simili, o vicine,
a quelle che noi stavamo cercando
quando abbiamo aperto la pagina.
Io sono napoletana,
se cerco un ristorante
a Londra il venerdì sera,
per prima cosa vedo pizzerie:
mai sia farmi vedere
un ristorante di sushi,
potrei avere una crisi isterica.
Google lo sa, quindi
previene la situazione.
Il profiling è una cosa buona,
fino a quando non diventa
ragione di discriminazione,
quando perpetra tra quelli
che sono i pregiudizi
che nella società già ci sono
e che l'intelligenza artificiale facilita.
Un altro esempio legato a Google:
alcuni anni fa è diventato famoso
il caso in cui l'algoritmo di Google
mostrava avvisi pubblicitari
per lavori manageriali
più spesso agli utenti uomini
che alle utenti donne.
È un caso di discriminazione,
questo è un rischio che dobbiamo evitare,
perché una società
in cui l'intelligenza artificiale
sarà sempre più distribuita,
non possiamo permetterci che si facilitino
e si distribuiscano e si moltiplichino
questi tipi di discriminazione.
Il secondo problema ha a che fare
con la natura di questa tecnologia.
Molto spesso l'IA è definita
come una black box:
cioè noi abbiamo gli input,
disegniamo la tecnologia,
ma non possiamo predire gli output.
Potremmo, certo, avendo la stessa capacità
di computazione, ma è difficile.
E questo perché è importante?
È importante perché noi
ci fidiamo dell'AI,
deleghiamo all'AI compiti importantissimi:
la diagnosi del cancro,
decidere chi assumeremo
al prossimo colloquio di lavoro,
in che ristorante andare il venerdì sera.
In realtà però ci fidiamo
di queste macchine che non comprendiamo
e di cui non abbiamo
predicibilità nel comportamento,
e anche questo è un aspetto importante,
c'è tanta ricerca che si focalizza
su questo argomento.
E l'altro aspetto ha a che fare
con l'uso dell'AI
e l'impatto sull'essere umano.
Abbiamo sentito prima
la quarta rivoluzione, no?
Una "Quarta Rivoluzione Industriale":
è una frase che ricorre spesso,
e la si usa per indicare il fatto
che siamo diventati società digitali.
In realtà la quarta
rivoluzione industriale
non è tanto il fatto
che troviamo gli amici su Facebook,
o che compriamo libri su Amazon,
ma è più il fatto che il nostro frigo
fa la spesa su Amazon,
avendo capito quello che ci piace
sulla base dei commenti
che scriviamo su Facebook,
è questa correlazione.
Ecco, l'AI facilità questa correlazione,
l'AI è un facilitatore invisibile
che media tra le interazioni,
le nostre interazioni con l'ambiente:
e nel mediarle, in realtà,
un po' ci dà degli indirizzi.
A che punto questi indirizzi
sono in contraddizione
con la nostra autodeterminazione,
con la nostra capacità di scegliere?
Il mio lavoro è, in parte,
anche essere sicuri che utilizziamo l'AI
a supporto della nostra determinazione,
non contro o a discapito della stessa.
Vi ho detto, appunto:
non sono solo rischi,
sono anche opportunità.
Il grande vantaggio dell'AI
è che ci permette di delegare compiti
che sono tediosi, noiosi,
a volte pericolosi, alle macchine,
e ci libera tempo.
In Inghilterra tutti abbiamo un giardino,
d'estate vorremmo fare delle feste,
ma non si arriva mai al sabato sera
con la voglia di farle,
perché hai speso tutta la giornata
a tagliare il prato.
E qualche tempo fa ho cambiato casa,
ho speso un weekend
a montare i mobili di IKEA,
liti che non posso descrivere,
non c'è una sedia
che sia in equilibrio a casa mia.
Quando ho scoperto
che c'erano robot guidati dall'AI
che potevano assemblare
i mobili IKEA da soli,
ho avuto un momento
di commozione inenarrabile.
E così guidare nelle zone trafficate,
e invece di spendere tempo a guidare,
poter leggere o interagire e via dicendo.
In una società in cui l'AI
sarà distribuita in maniera orizzontale -
sarà dovunque, nelle nostre tasche,
sui cellulari, nel nostro tostapane,
nel nostro termostato, in ospedale,
a scuola, in ufficio -
il compito è essere sicuri che più AI
significhi più "human flourishing",
cioè la capacità
di sviluppare e realizzare
i nostri progetti esistenziali,
i nostri progetti umani,
sia a livello individuale,
sia a livello sociale.
Nel 2015 l'ONU ha definito
quelli che si chiamano
i "sustainable development goals":
sono 17 sfide che dobbiamo raggiungere
con successo entro il 2030,
che permetteranno all'umanità
di vivere meglio,
fare meglio, stare meglio.
E vanno dalla ricerca
nell'ambito biomedico
alla cura della salute,
la protezione dell'ambiente,
la parità di genere, la diversità.
Abbiamo scoperto, abbiamo capito
che l'intelligenza artificiale
può aiutare e facilitare
lo sviluppo di tutti questi obiettivi.
Ci sono applicazioni dell'AI
che permettono a dei contadini in India
di capire quando seminare
per massimizzare il raccolto
date le condizioni climatiche.
Abbiamo applicazione dell'AI
che facilitano la raccolta
delle plastiche dagli oceani,
che è una delle tragedie ambientaliste
forse più sentite al giorno d'oggi.
Sappiamo che nel 2050 ci saranno
131 milioni di persone
malate di Alzheimer,
una malattia che non possiamo curare,
che è difficile da diagnosticare,
e abbiamo capito che l'AI ci permette
di anticipare la diagnosi di sei anni,
limitando così l'impatto della malattia
perché possiamo curarla prima.
Allora com'è che tutti questi rischi
e tutte queste opportunità,
come ci impattano, come ci affliggono
in quanto esseri umani?
La risposta che do spesso è questa,
è una frase di Leonardo da Vinci
che dice: "Sono stato impressionato
dall'urgenza del fare.
Sapere non è abbastanza, dobbiamo agire.
Avere ottime intenzioni
non basta, dobbiamo fare".
E uno davanti alle potenzialità dell'AI
uno è davvero preso dalla voglia di dire,
"Beh allora sfruttiamola,
non ce la perdiamo, cambiamo il mondo".
A leggerla anche un po' superficialmente,
sembra quasi di leggere
uno di quei motti della Silicon Valley.
Qualche anno fa, a San Francisco,
avrebbero detto "fail often, fail fast":
non ti preoccupare se sbagli,
ripeti lo sbaglio,
l'importante che ti riprendi e riprovi
e continui a provare:
prima o poi fai le cose fatte bene.
Nel [frattempo] abbiamo avuto
Cambridge Analytica
e tutti gli scandali
di cui abbiamo sentito,
quindi non è proprio una buona idea.
In realtà Leonardo non ci sta dicendo
"fail often, fail fast".
Leonardo è un uomo del Rinascimento,
è un uomo poetico,
il suo fare segue al pensare,
è utilizzare lo strumento di oggi
per cambiare il domani.
Il fare significa progettare:
e in realtà ce lo dice,
ci dice che la conoscenza
non è abbastanza.
È necessaria, ma non è sufficiente.
Le buone intenzioni
servono, ma non bastano:
bisogna fare di più, ma ci vogliono.
Allora quali sono le buone intenzioni,
quali sono le conoscenze
che ci servono al giorno d'oggi
per poter fare come avrebbe
voluto Leonardo,
cioè progettare il futuro?
E qui arriva un altro po' di filosofia,
ma è veramente poca.
L'AI è una tecnologia,
forse una delle più avanzate
o la più avanzata, del digitale
e il digitale è una
tecnologia rivoluzionaria,
non solo perché ci permette
di fare cose nuove,
ma perché nel farlo
cambia la realtà intorno a noi,
è una tecnologia trasformativa.
Col digitale facciamo nuove cose,
appunto potremmo leggere
un libro mentre guidiamo.
Ma cambia anche il modo
in cui capiamo le cose.
Pensate al concetto di guerra,
che è una delle aree
in cui lavoro molto io.
La guerra, nella storia dell'umanità,
ha significato violenza,
distruzione, morte.
Oggigiorno parliamo di "cyber conflicts",
di conflitti cibernetici
che sono sì una espressione di forza,
sono un'espressione di aggressività,
ma sono completamente staccati
dal concetto di violenza.
Possiamo combattere una guerra cibernetica
senza uccidere nessuno,
senza distruggere niente,
eppure raggiungere lo stesso obiettivo.
È cambiato un concetto:
quello di guerra, che era un concetto
che equivaleva a forza e violenza,
è diventato un concetto in cui, invece,
la violenza è staccata da quello di forza.
Questa trasformazione dell'ambiente,
delle nostre interazioni,
della nostra comprensione
che digitale e l'AI fanno
sono la leva, sono l'elemento
sul quale dobbiamo spingere
per capire in realtà,
per raggiungere quel "fare"
che Leonardo ci suggerisce.
Qual è, quindi,
la natura o il valore dell'essere umano
nella società del digitale,
nella società dove le macchine
si comportano come se
fossero intelligenti?
E noi possiamo delegare all'AI
il potere computazionale:
l'intelligenza artificiale
può raccogliere informazioni,
elaborare informazioni, fare correlazioni
in una maniera più veloce, più precisa
di qualsiasi altra intelligenza
che noi conosciamo.
Immaginate la diagnosi del cancro:
l'intelligenza artificiale può riconoscere
da una tac un cancro senza mai stancarsi,
senza mai dimenticarsi
nessuna delle tac che ha visto prima,
senza avere un momento di stress,
un momento di paura.
È super efficiente, ma questa è la delega.
L'AI è uno strumento,
uno strumento che dobbiamo utilizzare
per cambiare la realtà in cui viviamo.
Dobbiamo utilizzare l'AI
per progettare le società:
la nostra società, ma anche quelle
che si chiamano le società "post-AI",
cioè quelle società nelle quali l'AI
non sarà più una tecnologia
trasformativa, rivoluzionaria,
ma sarà [considerata] un po'
come la corrente elettrica
ai giorni nostri.
Dobbiamo utilizzare l'AI
per essere sicuri di sviluppare società
che siano tolleranti, che siano giuste,
che siano democratiche,
che siano pluraliste.
L'ordine delle parole non è casuale:
tolleranza è un valore fondamentale
in questo contesto.
Allora se guardiamo
al design intelligente,
perché è importante?
Beh, perché il design intelligente,
alla maniera di Leonardo,
intelligente alla maniera
della progettazione del futuro,
è quello che ci fa umani
ed è la cosa che l'AI non fa
e che noi facciamo.
E abbiamo la responsabilità di farlo,
perché si tratta di dare la forma
alla realtà che seguirà
quella dei nostri figli.
Io vi lascio con una citazione
di Winston Churchill,
che era uno anche abbastanza cinico,
però ci vedeva molto bene
per quanto riguardava il futuro.
Una volta ha detto:
"We shape our buildings and then,
afterwards, our buildings shape us",
diamo noi una forma ai nostri palazzi,
però poi i palazzi danno una forma a noi.
L'architettura ci dice questo.
Questa frase è vera per l'architettura,
e ancora più vera per il digitale,
e ancora più vera per l'AI.
Noi disegniamo l'AI, noi progettiamo l'AI:
e dobbiamo sapere
che questa tecnologia, poi,
ha un impatto molto diretto
e molto forte su noi come persone,
su noi come società, su noi come ambiente.
Allora dobbiamo essere sicuri
di progettare l'AI
in modo tale che ci permetta
di acquisire la forma che vogliamo,
una forma in cui l'empatia
rimane un valore fondamentale,
un aspetto da curare,
da proteggere e da distribuire.
E con questo vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)